I am really excited to have such a full room and I know we have a lot of people
on the live stream and a lot more people still who can't make either and are
looking forward to seeing this up on youtube,
which will be the case.
Uh,
in the next few days.
I'm really excited to introduce Professor Carol Dweck from Stanford University.
She's the Lewis and Virginia eat and professor of psychology.
She is best known for her work on mindsets that people use to guide their
behavior.
She earned a BA in psychology from Columbia University and then a phd in
psychology from Yale sees the author of a bestselling book,
a mindset,
the new psychology of success.
And despite traffic,
uh,
a bunch of books arrived at the back of the room,
which you can purchase afterwards.
I certainly encourage you to do so.
There's Mike,
well thumbs copy,
it sold over a million copies.
So there are many of your friends out there who have enjoyed this work.
She's a frequent speaker,
has spoken on the Ted Stage Multiple Times at the United Nations,
the White House among other prestigious organizations.
Her work has won so many awards that I find named them all.
That would be the entire talk.
So I'm not going to do that.
And now that I have incredibly boosted or are you go,
I'd like to bring up professor to way
[inaudible].
All right,
before we get into mindsets,
I want you to share what we've learned from what is now the widely discredited
theory of self esteem and the self,
the steam.
In the 1990s,
the self esteem movement took over the world.
Uh,
we were told to tell everyone how fabulous,
brilliant,
talented,
special day where all the time this was going to motivate them and boost their
achievement.
Instead,
as you said,
it was a complete disaster.
It was led to the acceptance of mediocrity.
It didn't challenge people to fulfill their potential.
And our search showed telling people they're smart actually backfires.
It makes them afraid of challenges.
It makes them a fold and the face of obstacles because they're worried,
oh,
does this not look smart?
Am I not smart?
The whole currency is built around smart.
Yes.
So what triggered your interest in,
in going deeper and in researching how people are motivated and learn and how
did that lead to your definition of mindsets?
I was always interested in why some people wilted in the face of failure,
shied away from challenges when people who were no more talented or able or
embracing challenges and thriving in the face of failure.
Ultimately,
this led to our discovery of the mindsets and what we found was that some people
believe their talents and abilities are just these fixed traits.
You have a certain amount and that's it.
But other people believe talents and abilities can be developed through hard
work,
good strategies,
good mentoring from others.
Um,
through years of work,
we found that having a fixed mindset led you to be afraid of challenges that
might unmask and your deficiencies made you withdraw and the face of difficulty
because you felt stupid.
You didn't want to feel stupid.
And when other people don't think you were stupid.
Whereas having this growth mindset,
the idea that your abilities could be developed made you think,
why waste my time looking smart when I couldn't be getting smarter?
And I do that through taking on challenges.
I do that through seeing,
seeing them through.
Now growth mindset doesn't mean everyone's the same,
that they don't different talent and abilities.
It just means everyone can grow.
It's sort of building on that you really can't watch a sports broadcast or the
TV show.
America's got talent,
which has telling them the name without hearing hotel did that player is,
or seeing someone performed the ballet and then say she has tremendous talent.
Um,
what role,
if any,
does innate talent play?
Yeah,
well they do have talent now when we were watching them,
but I think it's created a nation that thinks when they see someone displaying
talent or incredible performance,
they were born that way and they've had this inevitable rise to great success.
I teach a freshman seminar at Stanford every year and I have my students do an
assignment where they do research on their hero and almost invariably they think
that hero just catapulted to success because of this amazing inborn talent.
Um,
but every single time they find that the hero put in inordinate amounts of work,
um,
met with obstacles and really powered through them.
Uh,
so I don't rule out the idea,
the fact that some people are born with passions and talents and build those,
but many people who never achieve anything are also born with talents and
passions that they don't see through.
Um,
and uh,
what's there,
what we come with.
That's the raw material that you,
you've got to develop Michael Jordan.
It turns out,
wasn't particularly talented until he went at it so ferociously more ferociously
than anyone else.
So you talked about over over lunch we had an itching discussion with part of
the team here about a growth mindset,
fixed mindset.
It's a great simplified way to think of it.
Yeah.
People can have both.
And it's more of a spectrum.
Talk a little bit more about,
about how you can be,
it'd be have both mine
since
we're all a mixture.
Um,
it's true that you can have a fixed mindset in one area and a growth mindset and
other area.
But even,
and it's true that it's a spectrum man,
a dichotomy,
but it's a really dynamic,
even in a given area,
sometimes you're in a fixed mindset using,
oh,
uh,
my ability to fix.
I have to prove them.
I have to look smart.
I can't show that I'm working too hard.
People might not think I'm so smart,
and other times we could be more in a growth mindset.
So what we have to start doing is looking for what triggers that?
Because the fixed mindset holds us back.
We have to start looking for what triggers it and all of us,
even me.
Um,
what happens when you're facing a big challenge?
Uh,
do you worry about,
well,
I'm going to unmask deficiencies.
What happens when there's a setback?
Do you think maybe I'm not good at this?
What happens when you're receiving criticism?
Do you get angry and defensive?
What happens when you see someone who's better at you and what you're good at?
Do you feel jealous and resentful or do you feel inspired?
Maybe I can learn from that person.
Maybe they can mentor me.
Uh,
so watch out at these trigger moments.
See how you're feeling and see if you can get yourself into more of a growth
mindset.
So I actually,
I have two children,
two daughters,
uh,
college age and high school age.
I,
I read your book,
uh,
after my older daughter was,
was uh,
approaching high school,
but my younger daughter benefited from it to the point where I've banned the two
s words that our house smart and stupid.
I never used the ladder,
but I was very guilty of using the former and raise your hands if you've used,
if you've told a friend or a child or a loved one,
how smart they are,
deal.
What's that?
Words are really powerful is one thing I took away from your book.
Talk about trigger words like that.
SMART,
stupid and how those can work against your best intentions.
Yes.
When you call someone smart,
you put them in a box or really you're kind of putting them on a pedestal and
their life becomes organized around deserving the pedestal,
staying on the pedestal.
And you can only do that by narrowing your life to include only things.
You're sure you're good at only things you're sure you can succeed at.
Um,
when we tell someone you did that so quickly,
I'm so impressed they here.
If I didn't do it quickly,
you wouldn't be impressed.
And a lot of things take a long time.
Um,
or Yay,
you got an,
you got an a without working then use,
they think,
oh,
if I work,
you're not going to think I'm smart at math.
Say.
And so that you're just very subtly conveying these ideas that I'm smart.
People don't make mistakes.
Smart people don't have to work hard.
The most important thing in the world is to be smarter and look smarter at all
times.
And then people start narrowing their world so they can succeed within that
fixed mindset.
So one thing a Google that we're obsessed with is,
is,
is proving things for data.
And I think one of the compelling arguments made was around the research you did
with children in a school environment to talk about some of that early research
and how it's evolved to reinforce that,
that there's weight behind this concept.
Yes,
we've done research now with
tens of thousands of students.
First finding that those who naturally have a growth mindset do better.
We've traced them over challenging,
especially in challenging courses like premed,
organic chemistry or challenging transitions.
Um,
seventh grade high school,
college transitions.
We've studied all of those recently.
We studied all of the 10th grade students in the country of Chile and we are
170,000.
And we found that at every level of family income,
those who believe they could develop their intelligence performed substantially
higher on achievement tests.
And those who thought they couldn't.
And the most striking thing was that among the poorest kids,
those who had a growth mindset,
we're performing at the level of much wealthier kids.
Um,
but importantly,
cause those are correlations.
We've done a number of studies where we have taught students at growth mindset,
the idea that every time they do a really hard task and stick to it,
the neurons in their brain form new connections and they can get smarter.
And when we show them how to put that into practice,
um,
we have found that students who learn this fair better across challenging
courses and transitions.
Uh,
we just,
uh,
showed that in,
um,
a study of women in stem classes at,
at universities around the country.
Uh,
but we've showed that,
shown that at the transition to college transition to high school and s and so
forth.
So teaching a growth mindset leads kids to take on the challenges dick to them
and improve.
So in our current education culture,
and then I want to switch into,
in the work environment,
there's such an obsession with standardized tests and those tests having a
Marilyn material impact on teachers advancement and even in some cases their
income.
How do you,
uh,
how do school systems battle on that front at the same time?
Uh,
tackle growth mindset,
which is more about working hard and process than the actual end result.
Yes.
It's such an interesting story because standardized tests were brought in for
good reason.
There were students in certain parts of the country and in certain schools who
were performing so poorly and nobody knew.
And nobody cared.
And it was an attempt to say let's not cheat kids out of a good education.
But we all know the unanticipated an an an an intended consequences school
became about standardized tests and many teachers feeling that their jobs or
their raises were on the line taught to the test the entire year.
How warning could that be for teachers or for students?
Um,
so,
and we did research to show that a lot of students think that those tests
measure how smart they are and how smart they'll be when they grow up.
So they're nervous about them and the whole year is spent on them when in fact,
if you just taught kids and uh,
in a way that made them love learning
to love challenges,
know how to stick to them,
um,
feel the thrill of improvement,
then the test score would come as a byproduct of that.
Finland,
the country that does so well on all of these international tests,
they don't teach to the test.
They teach,
the teachers love teaching,
the kids love learning and they do well on the test.
Let's get back to that here.
So going into the corporate environment,
can you actually think of an organization is a growth mindset organization or a
fixed mindset organization?
You do talk about Enron and then your book is an example of a,
probably not the positive side.
So talk about how you could look at it from an organizational level and then if
you want your culture to be a growth lights at culture,
how do you start to,
yes,
yes.
Um,
so in my book I identify organizations that I'm valued talent,
raw talent above all else or that valued,
um,
believed in everyone's to improve and develop and valued.
That.
In our recent work,
we've actually gone in and asked the people,
we asked employees in different fortune 500 organizations,
well,
what mindset does your company have?
Is it a company that believes in fixed talent and worships it?
Or is it a company that believes everyone can develop their abilities and really
provides these opportunities?
And,
uh,
what we found was there was remarkable consensus within organizations about,
um,
which mindset their organization has and more important,
it made a big difference.
So in terms of that difference,
uh,
you can kind of compare and contrast companies that you view as leaders in
growth mindset versus those that have struggled,
uh,
maybe because of a fixed mindset or culture.
Well,
in this research we found that employees and fixed mindset,
let me go the other way.
That employees and growth mindset organizations said they felt more empowered by
the organization and more committed to it,
whereas their counterparts in the more fixed mindset organizations,
uh,
kind of had one foot out the door waiting for the next highest bidder.
But to me,
uh,
what was even more interesting is that the people in growth mindset
organizations said their company's valued creativity,
innovation,
and they really put their money where their mouth was.
So if you took a reasonable risk and it didn't work out,
they said,
my company has my back,
my company really values teamwork was another thing they said in the growth
mindset organizations in the more fixed mindset organizations,
the employees said,
yeah,
the company talks innovation and creativity.
But if things don't work out,
someone pays the price.
And finally,
the managers in the growth mindset organizations said,
um,
that their employees had tremendous potential to rise within the organization,
become stars,
joined management.
Um,
whereas,
and I love this finding cause in the fixed mindset organization,
they're worshiping the talent and hiring the talent and paying to keep the
talent.
But if you years later they're not saying there are a lot of people who have
potential to rise in the organization,
either they've left or they don't have that potential anymore.
Many of us in the room and participate in interviewing potential candidates for
Google.
So let's assume for a second that,
that Google's trying to have a growth mindset that it is that,
what are strategies interviewers can use to help identify that training people
or identify that someone would be open to going down that path?
Great question.
Uh,
I worked with a major league baseball team,
so I'll talk about that first,
um,
to device questions,
uh,
that they could ask to potential draft choices.
Uh,
one was how'd you get so good at baseball?
And some of them said,
well,
you know,
I was born with this natural talent.
And others said,
well,
my father and I,
we worked at it constantly.
We had a batting cage in the back yard.
He filmed me,
we watched the tapes and so forth.
Um,
another one was,
um,
thinking about on field success in the major leagues,
what do you think you'd have to change?
And some of them said things like,
I'll have to get used to the cheering of larger crowds.
And others said,
maybe everything,
I'll have to take all my skills to a new level.
It's a whole new ball game.
So this knowledge that you might have to really reorganize,
redefine yourself and build new skills,
it's really important.
Taking that to the corporate setting.
First I might ask people what their greatest failures were.
See whether they take responsibility and,
um,
what they did with that failure.
Did they capitalize on it to do something
even better than they could have imagined?
Did,
did they use it to put value added back into the company?
Or on the other hand did they say,
well,
I,
I had this failure,
I worked too hard.
Or you know,
do they make it something that's really,
uh,
that really reflects well on them or was it someone else's fall?
And then this kind of readiness to learn readiness to,
um,
share credit,
these,
these kinds of questions.
But I've debated this,
uh,
your,
theories of buying set with colleagues over lunch,
particularly my last company,
there was really this resistance to except that talent and,
or,
uh,
intelligence were in any way malleable.
But talk about that for a minute.
His intelligence truly something that's valuable and maybe are there
physiological differences between,
um,
uh,
people that you've researched that are identified as growth mindset or fixed
bikes.
So we absolutely know that skills and abilities are malleable and that's kind of
what counts.
That's what turns itself into performance.
But there have been fascinating studies,
um,
at first of all looking into the brains of fixed and mindset people as they,
work on a hard task and make errors.
And you see that,
um,
the people who are in a growth mindset or having the relevant areas of the brain
really light up catch fire as they processed the errors and correct them,
whereas in the brains of the people who are in more of a fixed mindset,
very little is going on.
They're seeing their errors and they're moving on as quickly as possible.
But my favorite study along these lines,
um,
tracked,
teenagers,
uh,
from the age of 14 to 18.
Um,
the teenage brain.
Our brains are still very malleable,
but the teenage brain is unbelievably malleable.
It's a time of tremendous potential growth.
And what they found over those four years was that,
um,
there were some kids who gained a lot in Iq points in math or verbal areas and
there were others that lost a lot of points and it tracked with the density of
their neurons in the relevant parts of their brains.
So,
uh,
we believe it's the kids who really went at it and took on the challenges and
worked hard.
We're creating these denser neurons and the others who didn't use it
lost it.
And I thought another interesting aspect of your research was,
and this could apply in education at home or in or in business,
is the proclivity to cheat,
uh,
based on the mindset that I've talked a little bit about that.
Yes.
Um,
we have studied that directly and we see that cheating,
um,
is more the desire to achieve and the actual cheating is more prevalent within a
fixed mindset.
Um,
within a fixed mindset.
If say you haven't done well on a subject before but you want a good grade,
you feel like,
oh,
I have to find some circuitous means.
Um,
but if you feel that there are many ways that you can do better through actual
learning,
you're more likely to do that.
So in one study after a poor grade,
um,
students who held more of a fixed mindset of their intelligence actually said in
advance.
They're seriously considering cheating on the next test.
So when you're in your recent Ted talk,
oh,
I want to say one more thing.
In,
in,
in our business study,
the people in the fixed mindset organizations said cheating and deception where
much more prevalent.
And think about it.
If I have to be smarter than you,
if I have to be the superstar,
I'm going to consider all different ways to look better than you look.
And if I have to keep secrets from you or hoard my knowledge from other people,
I'm going to do that.
But in the growth mindset organization where people are collaborating and
learning and tackling challenges together,
where's the cheating going to come in?
It isn't.
So if a company,
uh,
observes that behavior and a couple of you to scale,
let's say it's not a company of 10 people that have hundreds or thousands and
they recognize this is we have a culture problem,
how do you go about even trying to tackle that where some of these strategies
companies can use if they decide we want to shift the culture,
we know it's going to take time.
It's not just a switch that you flip,
but what are some of the strategies or company could employ to change the
culture?
So I think,
uh,
the,
the best thing is for the message to come down from the top where they don't
just announce where a growth mindset culture,
they really explain what the new value system is.
The new value system on taking on challenges,
on rewarding a reasonable risk on teamwork,
on sharing information,
um,
uh,
giving performance evaluations that speak to people's growth and contribution to
the company in terms of learning and um,
uh,
salary increases that take into account.
Uh,
did someone take on challenges,
improve,
help other people improve where they a good team player?
Uh,
bottom line counts,
but these things also count.
So to have to kind of talk growth mindset talk without backing it up.
I don't think that's going to happen.
If you have the old reward system that's um,
uh,
rewarding kind of individual jockeying for a claim in power,
but if you back it up with evaluations,
rewards and,
and mentoring and what a growth mindset deeply means and how it can be enacted
within the job,
I think that that's a great start.
A new recent Ted talk he talked about the power of yet,
which I thought was a very interesting concept of,
a little bit about what you meant by that.
Yes.
Um,
it all started when I learned about a high school in Chicago where students had
to pass maybe 84 units to graduate.
And if they didn't pass a unit,
they got the grade.
Not yet.
I thought that isn't that great because if you get a failing grade,
do you think I hate this,
I'm outta here.
I'm no good at this.
Um,
and you kind of lose your steam,
but not yet.
It means,
hey,
you're,
you're on a trajectory,
a learning trajectory.
Maybe you're not as the finish line,
but you're on your way there.
And the students went around the school unabashedly saying to each other,
how many,
not yet.
Do you have?
I is do you have,
so we started a program of research.
It's still continuing on the word yet.
And um,
uh,
showing that saying not yet after a wrong answer keeps up motivation and
encourages persistence.
Uh,
so just saying and listen to yourself if sometimes you say,
I'm not a person or I could never didn't move,
then just add the word yet.
And if it takes a very,
or,
or if one of your employees as I can't do,
I'm no good at this.
Yeah.
It takes a very fixed mindset statement and it puts it in a whole different
growth mindset con context.
Just a second.
Last question for me is,
is you did some itching research very recently around a gaming and gave me
applied to math and talk a little about how you were able to incorporate your
concept of the growth mindset into that experience.
We teamed up with,
um,
Azurin Popovich and his colleagues at the University of Washington to create a
mass game,
uh,
called brain points that incorporated growth mindset principles.
There were algorithms built into the game that detected the student's effort,
their use of strategies and their improvement.
Okay.
And then in our experiment,
we compared Barain points to the standard version of the game.
Now the standard version of the game is that your usual game where the more you
zoom through and answer problems correctly,
the more you rack up points,
not in brain points.
Actually a few to through it apologizes to you and said you didn't earn any
points that time.
We're sorry,
we'll give you something more challenging the next time.
Um,
so what happened was this first students played,
uh,
these were a great school students.
They played longer cause they could leave the game at any point.
They played significantly longer.
Um,
they used more strategies.
We dropped in difficult problems.
Occasionally they s they persevered them longer.
But this was my favorite finding in the standard version.
It was mostly the high achievers who played to the end.
But in the brand points version,
they,
they stayed in,
they play to the end.
They liked it.
But so many more lower and medium achievers also stayed till the end.
Cool.
So what keeps you up at night as you think about where your research can go on?
Because like any scientific endeavor,
it's closer.
You're being challenged and revisiting what,
what keeps you up at night worrying about where your theory can be right or
wrong or approved.
Yeah.
Yes.
I always had this attitude of challenging my ideas and my theories because if
you're wrong,
you want to know it as soon as possible.
You don't want to spend your life on it.
Um,
so what keeps me up at night in a good way are different areas where it could be
applied.
So we have a whole program of research on,
um,
peace in the Middle East where we're using mindset,
principals,
mmm.
I'm not minimizing the hugeness of the problem,
but we're using mindset principles too.
MMM.
Try to build some greater understanding.
Um,
so I love to think of ways that we can extend it into areas we never thought of
before.
Uh,
I love to think of ways to implement it so that more kids who need this way of
thinking can benefit from it.
And something that also keeps me up at night is the fear that people are
developing what I'm calling a false growth mindset.
It's this idea.
If it's good,
I have it.
So a lot of people are kind of declaring they have it,
but they don't.
They think it just means open minded or being a nice person or um,
there,
um,
maybe they're saying they have it from fixed mindset reasons that I want you to
judge me,
um,
as,
as being the right kind of person.
Um,
so developing a growth mindset is really a journey.
It's a lifelong journey of,
um,
of,
uh,
monitoring your trigger points and,
and trying to approach things.
And I'm more growth mindset way of taking on the challenges,
sticking to them,
learning from them.
Um,
so,
um,
right now I'm writing something for educators that I'm calling false growth
mindset,
um,
to,
to tell them no,
you can't just say it.
You have to take a journey because we're doing research now showing that many
teachers and parents who say they have a growth mindset are actually responding
to kids in ways that are creating fixed mindsets for the kids.
So those are,
that's kind of the array of things that keep me up at night.
But that said,
I do sleep pretty good.
Wow.
All right.
With that,
we'll open up for questions from the,
uh,
from the audience and I'm going to take a quick look at the dory too.
So the Mike's give you passed around.
Hi.
Um,
I was introduced to fix your broken a couple of years ago and I have like 15
nieces and nephews and I find myself when I'm with them,
I don't know what to say to them because I don't want to be like,
oh you're so smart cause I'm not supposed to use that word or whatever.
But then I,
it's like,
I forget what to say when they're telling me about friends at school or problems
they're having.
It's things like that sounds really hard.
I mean,
am I just supposed to say like,
well that's hard.
You know,
I can do hard things.
You can do hard things.
Do you have any advice?
Okay.
Okay,
the good.
The question is,
if you can't say smart,
what can you say?
You can say so many other things.
One thing is you can just show interest in the,
in the process that the child or other person is engaging in it.
And our research,
that's what we've shown is effective focusing on the process or appreciating the
process someone is,
is engaging in or that has engaged in.
So just show interest,
ask questions,
give encouragement.
If they've,
um,
been grappling with something and they've tried new strategies or,
or stuck to the strategies,
um,
one parent said,
oh,
I hate it cause I can't appreciate when my child does something great.
It's like,
well where did you get that from?
Of course you can appreciate it,
but then tie it to something they engaged in.
Oh you couldn't do that yesterday.
You made progress.
That's so exciting.
Oh that's great.
You really stuck to it and learned it.
Or,
uh,
you tried all different ways and look,
that worked.
So you're,
you're,
you're really appreciating some outcome where they are and you're talking about
how they got there.
But if you don't have that information,
just ask them never praise effort that isn't there.
Got a question from our dory and then we'll go back to the room.
So a question for the door.
He is,
how do you think shame plays a role in growth and the growth mindset fixed
versus growth?
Oh,
that's a great question.
We have studied that and um,
we have shown that shame is a big factor and a fixed mindset.
Um,
you don't want to take on a challenge.
It's humiliating to have a setback within a fixed mindset.
It means you're not the person you want to be and other people aren't going to
look at you in the same way we've studied in an adolescence.
Um,
adolescents in a fixed mindset feel incredible shame when they are excluded or
rejected and that makes them want to lash out violently.
Uh,
so this and research,
uh,
of,
of for many years,
many people's research has shown that shame is not a productive emotion.
It makes you want to hide or lash out,
both of which are not going to get you in the long run where you want to be in a
growth mindset,
you can feel very disappointed.
You can feel her,
you can feel guilty,
you can feel a lot of things,
but these are emotions that allow you to go forward and be constructive
computer science,
education and diversity in that.
So I'm curious if you've looked into how stereotypes may interact with growth
mindset.
Like for instance,
you know,
thinking that math is not for girls,
how does that interact with growth mindset?
Yes.
Um,
so how does the growth mindset interact with stereotypes?
We've done extensive research on that.
Um,
we find a,
so a fixed mindset would be the belief that I can't do math,
girls can't do math,
et cetera.
And a growth mindset is it's a learned set of skills.
Anyone can get better at them.
So notice first of all,
that a stereotype is a fixed mindset label.
It says it's fixed and certain groups have in certain groups don't.
But in our research,
we also find that when females have a fixed mindset about math or computer
science,
they're more vulnerable to the stereotypes.
Um,
so in one study that we did at Columbia University,
we found that when women in Calculus had a fixed mindset about their calculus,
their math abilities,
when they encountered stereotyping,
where they felt their classmates or the professors thought women weren't as good
as men,
they fell prey to that.
So as we track them over their semester,
they started thinking,
I don't belong here.
I don't like this anymore.
I don't have confidence.
I can succeed in this area.
And ultimately they did not intend to as much to take it in the future.
Whereas this,
they had a growth mindset.
They did not like the stereotyping,
but it didn't speak to them.
It didn't,
they didn't believe that they couldn't improve,
learn and succeed.
They mean so they maintained their confidence.
They maintain their enjoyment of math and they maintain their,
um,
desire to take math in the future.
We just finished a study of women in computer science and are finding very
similar things.
In addition to finding that teaching a growth mindset is helping women with Stan
the stereotypes,
maintain their interest,
maintain the sense that it's a field they belong in.
And,
um,
these result in higher grades in the course.
So we're very,
very interested in that intersection between,
um,
growth mindset and stereotyping.
We also are finding at the transition to college that learning a growth mindset
helps,
um,
students from underrepresented groups in general,
even more because it helps them deal with stereotypes that they might encounter.
Interesting.
Got Another question here,
which I think is an interesting a take.
Do you see any context in which a fixed mindset is more beneficial than a growth
mindset?
Well,
first let me say that a gross mindset doesn't require you to go around improving
everything.
You can focus and you can decide,
no,
I'm not going to do that.
No,
I'm not going to do that,
but we're search,
uh,
not my research,
but the research of others has in fact looked at this question and found two
areas so far and which a fixed mindset is better.
One is sexual orientation.
People who accept that this is who they are and this is who they're meant to be,
um,
seem to be better adjusted than people who think I should be changing.
And the other is,
um,
aging.
So it's,
it's nice to feel you can stay young,
um,
through exercise and so forth.
But people who run around nipping and tucking and the Tummy Tuck and the this,
that and the other.
And it's kind of a Jess Brit,
a attempt to,
um,
retain extreme youth.
That doesn't seem to be so great either.
But when it comes to skill areas,
it looks like a growth mindset is typically more avid advantageous.
Could you identify specific behaviors?
Did one can try to advance you on the journey for an open mindset?
And how do you know that you're not kidding yourself or falsely believing that
you are one?
How do you know when you got there?
Yes.
Great question.
What are some specific behaviors do you can do to get yourself on the road to a
growth mindset?
Here are some ideas.
So first,
if you have a choice of something safe versus a challenge,
take the challenge.
If you hit an obstacle,
try to interpret it in a growth mindset way.
So what can I learn from this?
What can I do?
Now,
as I mentioned before,
if you see someone who's better than you,
go learn from them.
Uh,
so those are a set of behaviors you can start doing in addition to as a also
mentioned before,
monitoring those fixed mindset triggers.
And the thing is that
it's a journey that one is always on.
It's not ever the case that you've arrived at a full permanent growth mindset.
It's something how that you have to look at all the time because even I hear,
so listen to that voice in your head at the trigger points.
Cause even I hear myself saying sometimes in my head,
I was never good at that.
Whoa,
what did I say that?
So listen to the,
that voice.
It's constantly running in your head.
And I actually recommend that as a very,
very first step.
Um,
the first few weeks that you embark on this journey,
don't push yourself to exhibit any growth mindset characteristics.
Just listen to that voice that says,
jump try this.
You might look foolish.
You made a mistake.
If people knew that they wouldn't look at you in the same way,
uh,
that person's better than me.
I hate them.
Just whatever that voice is saying and your head,
listen to it and even do it with friends.
Discuss it.
Or when you see someone doing something that looks effortless,
are you thinking,
oh,
they're just brilliant,
talented.
Catch yourself thinking that or someone who's struggling.
Um,
do you,
are you thinking,
oh,
they're not really good at that.
Albert Einstein says,
I,
I'm not that smart.
I'm not smarter than other people in Amen did you said I just stick to things
longer.
That's why people thought it was slow originally.
He knew he didn't understand time,
space,
energy and so forth.
So I would say the very first step is the first few weeks.
Just listen to that fixed mindset voice.
It's there.
We all have it.
And if you don't hear it,
it will rule your behavior.
Thank you for coming.
I actually read your book right before I started at Google.
And I know I have a very fixed mindset and this is sort of a fixed mindset
question even.
But have you seen,
um,
patterns in who,
you know,
which kids have fixed mindsets?
Do you see,
is it,
are there differences across socioeconomic lines?
Do you see that certain teachers,
most of their students will have the growth mindset or,
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Do you see patterns with who has the growth,
the growth mindset and how,
how does that happen to kids?
Yes.
So first of all,
I don't rule out that there could be temperamental factors.
You kids pop out differently and um,
some of them you see they're tearing around the world.
May they fall down,
they get up.
And then other,
uh,
other kids,
you look at them sideways and they think,
what did I do?
Um,
so there could be these temperamental factors,
but we've shown the environment is really powerful.
We actually did a study where we looked at mother's praise to babies and found
that the praise they gave to their one,
two and three year olds predicted the child's mindset and desire for challenge
five years later.
So that environment is powerful.
Uh,
another thing we found is that the way parents react to kids' mistakes is a big
determinant of the child's mindset.
Parent can say,
I have a growth mindset,
but if,
if a child makes a mistake and they
act like it's negative,
important to be negative,
or even if they excuse it and gloss over it in a way that communicates to the
child,
it's negative.
That child is more likely to have more of a fixed mindset.
So yeah,
there can be temperamental input.
The environment is powerful.
Right.
I want to thank you so much for taking time to come to Google today and for the
terrific turnout that we have here,
and I know a virtually to the livestream,
so thank you very much.
Pleasure.